what's up guys so I have been waiting
for a Wolverine trailer for a while and
it seems like I've been waiting longer
than usual because usually with big
movies like this they released a trailer
really fast like a year ahead of time or
it may be even like six months ahead of
time this movies come out in July we
just got our first look at this movie
today and I am pumped to tell you guys
about it but I want to tell you guys
something really quickly as you know
I've been trying to be a little more
supportive of channels that I like a lot
of times you guys asked me about
channels I like and I've been trying to
find the perfect time and I can mention
a channel to you guys that I've been
diggin and this channel it's called Tom
PO now they do videos that are in 3d and
I thought Wolverine 3d this is the best
chance that I can get to tell you guys
that I like this channel Tom Poe the
reason I'm telling you guys about this
is because I've been getting constant
tweets Facebook messages YouTube
messages emails asking me what kind of
channels I like besides movie reviewers
and this is one of them so since I'm
going to be talking about Wolverine 3d
today and also going to be seeing GI Joe
retaliation in 3d later I thought I'd
recommend you guys to go check out Tompa
I put a link for that channel check them
out and let them know I sent you so the
trailer for The Wolverine debuted today
and I immediately ran and watched it as
soon as I possibly could because despite
the fact the last two x-men movies x-men
3 and x-men origins were not good in my
opinion
I'm still a really big fan of this
character and Hugh Jackman's betrayal of
him I think he does a very good job and
I honestly can't imagine anyone else
playing Wolverine at this point yes he
is taller than Wolverine is in the
comics no he doesn't wear a yellow
spandex thank goodness but I think he
understands the essence of that
character and provides more depth than
some of the comics even did for him at
least in the first two x-men movies
anyway this movie is directed by James
Mangold who has made a lot of good
movies in the past like walk the line
identity or 3:10 to Yuma and even his
weaker films like night and day still
had really well directed action and with
this trailer you get the sense that
Logan or Wolverine has offered this sort
of ultimatum there's a possibility that
he can have his immortality removed
maybe he can have his powers removed in
that sense he's not gonna be able to
heal anymore I can make you believe it
before now what this does for him as a
character is it makes him so much more
vulnerable and for that reason we're
gonna be able to relate to him much more
as a person and I've been saying that
lately in my videos we need more action
heroes who are actually vulnerable who
aren't just these indestructible people
I mean yes you got movies like The
Avengers where that's supposed to be
that way but even those characters were
vulnerable as people they were at their
weakest point as a group as a core yes
they were very strong and be able to do
superhuman things but as a core they
were weak and they needed to be strong
together the best types of comic book
films are those ones where you get to
see those characters rise above the
situation that you can understand a
challenge that you can understand as a
mere mortal and so that makes me excited
about the Wolverine because it seems
like we'll be able to relate to him more
as a character it's well filmed lots of
wide angles it looks good Hugh Jackman
as always looks good in the role I'm
consistently astounded by that man's
lack of body fat my only issue I would
say with the trailer is it looks like
there's a little bit more CGI than I
would expect or maybe want I was hoping
for a little bit more straightforward
hardcore gritty style now granted the
CGI isn't entirely finished so possibly
when it is it will look a little bit
better but I'm still excited for the
Wolverine what do you guys think of this
trailer I left a link for the trailer in
the description below please tell me
what you thought of it I am pumped to
see it I've been excited for it for a
while because I really think that it can
be a return to form for that character
and I'm hoping for a dark gritty
adaptation of this character that is
realistic and
very exciting as a popcorn film what
they did to me why I am can't be undone
don't be so sure I'll be back later
tonight with my review of GI Joe
retaliation and as always if you liked
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes